E aí
[Aplausos]
e eu quero começar dividindo com vocês
dois momentos na minha vida que me
causaram a grande transformação uma
esfera pessoal e outro na Esfera
profissional
e não espera pessoal a maternidade é o
que pode parecer clichê mas é um grande
momento de transformação e tive alguns
Episódios específicos que me causaram
bastante surpresa um foi com meu filho
no primeiro filho de 2 aos dois anos
quando ele a uma vez escovando o dente e
deixando a pia aberta com água
escorrendo ele me falou mãe desliga
Senão vai acabar água do planeta eles
são dois anos de idade e eu não estava
dando aquele exemplo para ele na escola
na cidade dele eu aprendi que a água é
um recurso infinito e ele já vinha me
dando as primeiras lições
um outro momento foi outro filho aos
seis anos de idade ao preencher uma
atividade da escola em que pedir Ah tá
que ele escolhesse em profissões o que
eles queriam ser quando crescer e ele
colocou o reciclador
é tão e ele não tinha nenhuma referência
do que eu fazia pelo menos Não nunca lhe
relatei expressamente o que eu fazia
então não foi diretamente influência da
minha parte mas sim uma compreensão que
essa pode ser uma atividade exercida por
alguém no futuro como ele desejou
Então essas experiências pontuais além
de muitas outras que eu vivi na
maternidade me fez pensar que na verdade
Nossas ações de hoje elas devem ser
direcionada parece futuras gerações mas
às vezes do que para as nossas gerações
Atuais
Eu tive um outro momento profissional
também que me causou uma grande
transformação
O que foi quando eu recebi um convite em
2014 para integrar a delegação
brasileira
na elaboração da Norma de certificação
internacional junto à organização
internacional de normalização
é a primeira reunião que eu participei
uma das primeiras essa Norma que foi em
Paris em 2014 Novembro 2014 e foi minha
primeira experiência talvez
internacional como advogada já tinha
conhecimento teórico através de um
estudo internacional de Eu também tá
comparado no Texas direito internacional
ambiental Nova York mas assim temos
experiência prática como advogado
internacional isso talvez essa minha
primeira e tudo pra mim a grande
surpresa na experiência e no primeiro
momento eu me deparei assim com diversas
delegações dos países que compunham
aquele time que estaria a responsável
que aderiram ao interesse de construir
uma Norma incomum e me vi diante de
tantas divergências diante de tantos
interesses distintos e diante de tantos
tanta compreensão the pharynx da
realidade uma situação assim de
dia imaginar que talvez fosse impossível
construída ali um consenso O que seria
um requisito para a construção de a
norma comum
ao longo desse processo normativo
passaram-se mais de dois anos com
reuniões em Londres com a reuniões aqui
no Brasil e na China em beijinho
uns construindo ao longo desse processo
um consenso um consenso no sentido de
construir
nossos interesses em comum uma Norma de
certificação
uma Norma que define se um padrão
adequado de comportamento
bom então essa experiência
pessoal juntamente com essa experiência
profissional foram dois momentos muito
marcantes na minha vida e que
transformaram substancialmente a minha
vida pessoal e também profissional
a máscara pessoal eu percebi que esta
geração que atualmente é que está
digamos assim na no centro do poder se
ela não se transformar imediatamente
e nós poderemos perder esse legado que
as futuras gerações estão construindo
uma consciência ambiental que nós não
aprendemos em nossa escola
é a minha experiência profissional me
fez entender a importância
das nossas ações por imaginar que a me
reunir com pessoas do mundo inteiro
importava para aquelas pessoas o que nós
no Brasil aqui na nossa cidade
fazemos
ou Agimos e que essa nossa ação tem um
impacto em termos Mundial me fez
compreender ou talvez reforçar a
importância de Nossas ações locais e
bom então esses dois momentos eles
transformaram muito a minha vida eu como
advogada como profissional é talvez
antes eu usava as leis precisava as leis
como meros instrumentos de construção de
teses jurídicas
utilizava as negociações os ajustes e
que fazia apenas como mera forma de
obter sucesso obter êxito nos endereços
que eu defendia a partir das
experiências
eu de por completo A minha atuação as
leis deixaram de ser instrumentos da
jurídicas para virar instrumento de
transformação social
e as negociações
deixaram de ser um espaço de conquistar
interesses
para ser um espaço de construir
consensos
a de construir uma forma de transformar
a sociedade de de forma equilibrada
Oi e fui daí dessa experiência que me
inspirou o tema da palestra que é uma
digital sustentável uma impressão que
conecta o mundo e digital a nossa
impressão digital
e a nossa impressão digital que a gente
tem desde quando nasceu e que ela é
única
a cada um tem a sua e Eu não impressão
digital é Nossa digital que nós deixamos
nossas marcas e nossa história nossos
antecedentes
e esse nossas digitais sustentáveis Elas
já estão em construção
embora às vezes a gente possa nem saber
disso e essa experiência internacional
demonstrou isso quando a gente relatava
o funcionamento corporativo brasileiro
esse funcionamento
já foi analisado para a construção da
normativa internacional pode digitar o
sustentável das corporações brasileiras
foram analisadas
as digitais individuais elas são a todo
momento analisadas
Oi e a construção dessa digital
sustentável nada mais é do que se
questionar na Esfera individual e na
Esfera coletiva nas organizações não
está individual e eu como profissional
da área de sustentabilidade sou muitas
vezes que adicionadas como é que eu
posso fazer diferença como é que eu
posso contribuir efetivamente para a
melhoria da sociedade
Quais são as minhas obrigações sociais e
ambientais
Oi e essa resposta eu não tenho talvez
ninguém tenha
e esse uma resposta que deve ser
levantada a cada momento a cada situação
em que vivemos em cada ambiente que
vivemos
tô a construção de eu digitar ostentava
na Esfera individual é a forma de a
gente está em cada situação e em cada
momento em cada ambiente se questionando
o que que eu já fiz para contribuir
efetivamente com a melhoria da sociedade
e eu assumo as minhas obrigações sociais
e ambientais como indivíduo
e com a minha responsabilidade diante de
todas Panorama
esse questionamento constante
individualmente é o que faz a construção
da Digital sustentável de um indivíduo
no ambiente coletivo
nas incorporações
nas organizações da mesma forma a
construção da Digital sustentável no
ambiente corporativo
ela também advêm desse casamento no
questionamento das políticas da empresa
das filosofias
das práticas sustentáveis Então hoje o
mundo se usa a tecnologia e SG e vai
aumente sou show governança que nada
mais é do que a construção de políticas
para implementar práticas sustentáveis
e para incrementar inclusão social
e para implementar a governança
corporativas
e isso é a construção de uma digital vem
impressão digital é você levantar o que
que essa Corporação
fez Qual é os descendentes essa
Corporação nessas esferas
estabilidade social
Econômica de governança
e o que elas pretendem fazer para frente
formato também on digital sustentável na
história corporativa e se questionar
diariamente Quais são as ações as
políticas as filosofias que devem ser
construídas pela Corporação para inserir
na sua dinâmica as práticas sustentáveis
e existem diversas formas de exercer
esse papel com essas diretrizes de
sustentabilidade
uma delas por exemplo é o nosso poder de
consumo seja como devido seja como
organizações coletivas nós poder de
consumo nos dá um instrumento de
escolher aquela empresa aquele serviço
Ou aquele produto que tenham em sua
cadeira cadeia produtiva
práticas sustentáveis
é um grande facilitador dessa escolha
são e certificações
Quais são as construções de normas que
fazem com que a gente possa ter a
garantia em um selo em uma certificação
específica de que aquele produto aquele
serviço foi avaliado e se certificou de
que ele tem uma cadeia produtiva
sustentável possui práticas sustentáveis
na sua atividade
bom então Esse instrumento facilitador é
um dentre tantos outros não existem
algumas diretrizes que elas precisam ser
seguidas pelos indivíduos e pelas
corporações para que a gente tenha a
garantia de que estamos construindo uma
digital sustentável e essa construção da
Digital sustentável ela não é apenas um
ato voluntário um diferencial na
sociedade de uma empresa
ela na verdade ela é a realidade de
sobrevivência
o que não assumir
essa obrigação essa postura esse
comportamento não mais será sustentáveis
não mais poderá permanecer em sociedade
seja uma empresa seja um indivíduo e
suas crianças que nos mostraram que o
meu filho de 2 anos e outro filho há
seis anos
bom então por exemplo a responsabilidade
no consumo ela instrumento poderosíssimo
você vê ao escolher um produto que você
compra você avaliasse aquela empresa tem
práticas sustentáveis que se possui
alguma certificação garantia de que ela
não tem condutas contra esses valores
é um grande diretrizes para a construção
de digital sustentável
a moto para outro passo é construção de
redes de relacionamento
e a gente tem visto aí até companhia de
que as ações individuais elas não são
suficientes mais vai são importantes mas
não suficientes
então se nós não Agimos coletivamente
diante de alguns interesses que são
coletivos
com a preservação ambiental como é que
usam social
e como desenvolvimento econômico os
resultados eles não serão suficientes
embora importantes mas não suficientes
a
multa diretriz
muito importante é a transparência da
comunicação não há mais espaço para
falta de Transparência
o Tom a organização e as redes sociais
mostram isso
e as conexões sociais emoções isso duas
corporações que não se apresentam de
forma transparente as pessoas que não se
apresentam de forma transparentes elas
também não terão mais espaço na
sociedade
bom então o que eu deixo de mensagem
para vocês é que vocês reflitam na e
pense o que vocês têm feito para as
futuras gerações
e o que você tem inserido na sua vida
seja como gestor de uma corporação seja
comum devido e seus diversos papéis em
termos de política sentem de diretrizes
para a construção de uma digital
sustentável
E aí